the wrath of khah is probably the best
of the Star Trek movies and had some
seriously iconic moments but actually
did it have a negative impact on the
following Star Trek
movies welcome to sck your SciFi TV
movie
[Music]
channel
Ronald De Mo recently did an interview
for screenr there's a link in the
description to the full story and in
that he actually talked about the wrath
of KH and how he felt there may have
been a slightly negative impact on the
following movies he says I got bored of
hearing from Executives who's the KH in
this
[Music]
movie where's the KH character how do we
get a character that you know is a bit
like KH
on come you still remember Admiral I
cannot help but be touched and that
every foll in Star Trek movie except
maybe for the Voyage Home had to have
some sort of uber super villain that was
reminiscent of
Khan we've seen the influence in strange
new Worlds how we now have a descendant
of c and actually in the second season
we even saw KH as a child suggesting
that his character is going to reappear
in that series at some point even though
that will massively change Canon but you
know Star Trek doesn't worry about
things like that but does this
suggestion by Ronald Mo actually hold
water well let's have a look at a couple
of the movies obviously we had Krug
played by Christopher Lloyd in Star Trek
three we had cbok in Star Trek five we
had General Chang played by Christopher
Plumber brilliantly in Star Trek 6 the
Undiscovered Country we had Captain
vadic played by his daughter Amanda
plumber in the last peard series which
you have to admit was very K esque in
style we've had the Bor queens and I
would argue Tom Hardy's shinzon
character in Star Trek n is was a
straight up copy I would actually argue
that the bulk of the movie was a
straightup copy remembering that in the
Wrath of Khan there is that iconic
[Music]
SE where Spock sacrifices himself to
repair the warp drive so they can escape
the blast of the Genesis weapon well in
Nemesis it was data that sacrificed
himself so that the Enterprise could
escape the Doomsday weapon of the
simitar and to be fair there's a few
moments in Star Trek Nemesis that is at
very least let's say reminiscent of Star
Trek of the wrath of KH even the big
battle with the citar towards the end is
actually fought in a nebula and you
could argue that the way the citar is
cloaked and that the enterpris is
hunting down their vessel and actually
fighting at a disadvantage is also very
similar to the battle in the wrath of
khah and it's not the only time Star
Trek has straight up copied The Wrath of
Khan let's remember the JJ Abram Star
Trek movies Into Darkness which again is
pretty much a straightup copy to me it's
a bit like it was written by somebody
that kind of remember seeing the wrath
of car when they were a kid like 30
years ago and wrote a new script based
on
it that's how it feels to me and they've
sort of got some of the details wrong so
in that movie Kirk sacrificed es himself
to repair the warp drive instead of
Spock and then Spock has to then save
cook because KH played by Benedict
Cumberbatch a smoke scream to conceal my
true
identity my name is KH I keep saying
that actually you have to be quite an
impressive director in a bad way to make
Benedict Cumberbatch look like a bad
actor but anyway he had magic blood in
that movie that even though Kirk was
dead and had been dead for quite a while
the magic blood saved him
so there's that um which is actually
very reminiscent of then basically they
saved Spock in the Search for Spock
basically using magic so does Ronald De
Moore who actually worked on several Big
Star Trek projects got a point did a few
of the Star Trek movies kind of become
Limited in scope by the success of Wrath
of khah because Executives were always
then looking to to replicate that
success well Ronald Mo says that
Executives kept putting pressure on to
get this klike character and that really
limited their storytelling ability when
the writer is telling you that then
really there's a problem if you're
always trying to emulate another project
it really does limit where you can go
with a storyline I would look at things
like the last of the Star Trek JJ Abrams
movies and point to um Idris elba's
character and say that that was very
limited in scope and when you've got an
actor like Idris a very very fine actor
and to have a story that I'm not 100%
certain made a lot of sense in lots of
ways it does limit where the writer can
go if they're being told constantly to
look at Star Trek The Wrath of Khan on
the flip side of this every story needs
a good protagonist don't they you need a
villain well not always always I would
actually argue that Star Trek the Voyage
Home even though the story makes no
logical sense is probably one of my
favorite movies I really think the wrath
of KH the Undiscovered Country and the
Voyage Home are my favorite of the
original
crew probably my favorite of any of the
Star Trek movies only first Contact
would really get into the conversation
and there was no major villain in that
even though obviously you have the
spaceship but there was no face on that
villain and it was still a brilliant
creative story if the writers hadn't
constantly had pressure on them to
actually create a a villain in each
movie and to have a face on that villain
I mean you could argue actually that
first Contact that they basically
created the queen because of this
pressure that they needed to have a
central figure within the Borg
Collective even though having a queen
really kind of goes against what the
Borg would were shown as up till that
point having a queen allowed them to
have that Central focal figure for the
villain role again did that come from
pressure from Executives because as I
say it didn't really make sense the
wrath of KH had such an iconic impact so
many moments within it that even
non-star Trek fans know like the back of
their hands that can you blame
Executives for wanting to replicate that
success in some ways when you create a
product that actually has such an impact
on culture can you blame them well I
would argue yes because you should
always try to move forwards you
shouldn't be trying to rely on the
successes of the past you should try to
create something new okay have little
nods to it like the last episode of
season four of um lower decks they
actually did an homage they did a
massive nod to The Wrath of Khan and it
wasn't subtle the whole point of the
series in lots of ways is that it's a
love letter to what has come before so
in that case it was brilliant it was a
little bit of a parody If you like and
it was done beautifully but when you
actually then create new movies that are
basically just trying to replicate
what's come before then really your
franchise is becoming stagnant
you're just trying to focus on what's
come before instead of looking to the
Future and trying to create something
new Star Wars is maybe guilty of this
once or twice itself and I'm sure other
franchises are too that when you get a
massive success that you're going to try
to replicate it and I just have to say
in my opinion it's lazy it's boring and
Star Trek have done it one too many
times for me but guys what do you think
why was the K success actually in the
long run a negative thing for Star Trek
were they trying to replicate has it
become a little bit stagnant and a
little bit boring because of it get into
the comments and tell me what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com for citre
where you get to see most of our videos
first and there's even a free trial and
you get a free gift after 3 months can't
say fairer than that also go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you to digest go and
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time